[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
merci à lalo schifrin tue beaucoup moins
connue que ta musique finalement et
cette musique géniale qui a fait le tour
du monde sur laquelle on danse encore
aujourd'hui à paris dans un endroit à
temps je citerai pas le nom tous les
mardis soirs truites qui joue trois
extraits de thé composition et puis
ensuite les gens comprendront qui tu es
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est mme alix
lalo schifrin en avant il y en a un
autre qui est pas mal aussi ses missions
apprécier les enfants un petit bout
[Musique]
elle
merci non c'est dingue parce que quand
cette quand cette boîte a ouvert il ya
dix ans c'est là dessus pendant ces avec
philippe routier ou à meilhan danser sur
mission impossible rivas un troisième
que je voudrais que la gentillesse de
jouer parce que alors là c'est le tube
total en france c'est les bâtiments
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
il
un peu tout
merci
alors merci beaucoup je suis très
heureux parce que tu es vraiment partie
des gens que j'idolâtre un peu et
j'aurais jamais pensé que je te
rencontrerait je connais ces tendances
shalit avait fait ça mais j'aurais
jamais pensé avoir la chance de te
rencontrer un jour je serai très heureux
que tu sois là je suis très contente
d'être ici c'est très à l'aise ses sales
gosses c'est vraiment tout va bien alors
il ya une chose que par contre que je ne
savais pas et ça m'a pas tellement
étonné parce qu'on adore les argentins à
paris c'est que tu es argenté en fait je
ne sais pas si c'est ça j'ai fait mes
études de musique classique et si j'ai
joué du jazz et la musique la musique de
film mais maintenant je reviens à paris
les 26 déjà un vivier pour faire au cas
des champs elysées le very special art
oui pour les vieilles spécial sur les
enfants handicapés indique t on vers une
gala avec leur caisse philharmonique de
paris oui et on va jouer pour fumer fois
en europe un concerto pour contrer pas
sûr qu est ce que tu as écrit j'ai écrit
ce que tu écris aussi la musique
classique oui mais ça tu as fait du jazz
avec stan getz avec sarah vonn avait les
immigrés spitz
mais je veux dire que la musique la city
ont va faire c'est très excitant on va
faire petrus qu'elle savait ni ni vote
ravel ma mère ravet est le concepteur de
contrat va et on l'appelle classique
mais hélas beaucoup de vitalité vigueur
j'espère que
ces 26 janvier au théâtre des
champs-elysées et que tu peux nous en
jouer un petit bout oui les concertos
classique que tu vas jouer le 26 juin à
ça je ne sais pas mais
je vais jouer un des deux thèmes le
concerto de contrebasse
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu